hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña juan pablo barrientos es
periodista y escritor y lleva años
denunciando los abusos sexuales
cometidos en el seno de la iglesia
católica de colombia es autor de los
libros dejad que los niños vengan a mí y
de este es el cordero de dios
precisamente este último se trata de una
investigación sobre el caso conocido más
adelante de abuso sexual cometido en el
seno de la iglesia católica declaró
colombia estamos hablando de la historia
de un joven abusado sexualmente y
obligado a prostituirse por 38
sacerdotes juan pablo barrientos
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
france 24
santiago hola saludos y gracias por la
invitación un placer estar aquí gracias
a ti y nuevamente juan pabló tu libro es
la historia de pedro un hombre por
supuesto ha cambiado por motivos de
seguridad claro está pero también la
historia de tres mujeres claves para que
la historia de pedro no quedará
enterrada comencemos precisamente por
ellas porque todo comenzó de una manera
bastante particular verdad el arzobispo
de la ciudad colombiana de villavicencio
encargó a tres mujeres todas creyentes
ellas por supuesto que conformen una
comisión cuyo objetivo era velar por el
cuidado de niños niñas también de
adolescentes finalmente descubrieron
denuncias que este obispo mismo estaba
ocultando y fueron elegidas creyendo que
iban a empatizar más con la iglesia que
con cualquier víctima verdad que pudiera
encontrar contamos cómo empezó todo esto
mejor resumen santiago e la génesis de
esta historia de la historia de pedro es
la historia prácticamente o parte de
tres mujeres dos de ellas que hacían
parte de una comisión que desde 2019 el
papá les ordenó a todos los obispos del
mundo crear para que los curas no violen
niños así de grave la situación en la
iglesia católica el papá les ordenó a
todos obispos que de estas comisiones
hubiera todo tipo de profesionales
incluyendo abogados
entonces faltaban los dos abogados en
villavicencio y es cuando el arzobispo
invita a dos mujeres jubiladas devotas
de misa diaria pero también madres de
familia son dos mujeres que se
desempeñaron en cargos
estatales que lo hicieron muy bien que
fueron disciplinados que fueron
responsables y que monseñor pensó que
porque ellas iban simplemente a misa
todos los días iban a contestar todo lo
que él estaba haciendo al encubrir a
todos esos sacerdotes y se equivocó pues
cuando estas dos mujeres escuchan
accidentalmente sobre la denuncia de
pedro pues se enfrentan al arzobispo se
enfrenta a toda la jerarquía y le exigen
al arzobispo que suspendas a los
sacerdotes y que llegue este caso
también a la autoridad civil la tercera
mujer que es claudia carrasquilla asumió
la defensa de pedro en toda esta batalla
que él tiene ahora con la iglesia y que
tiene la fiscalía general entonces es
una historia trágica la historia del
abuso de este hombre pero es una
historia también esperanzadora y es la
historia de tres mujeres creyentes que
se enfrentaron a las más altas jerarcas
colombianos absolutamente ahora juan
pabló estas tres mujeres que han sido
claves no fundamentales y también tu
investigación terminaron por sacar a la
luz el caso conocido más adelante de
abusos sexuales cometidos en el seno de
la iglesia católica colombiana el de
pedro por supuesto todo abuso juanes
aberrante pero el caso de pedro en que
te centras en el libro tiene
características que lo hacen
particularmente
escalofriantes podrías contarnos su
historia por favor
es un hombre que no tiene familia no
tiene papá no tiene mamá no tiene a
quien recurrir es un hombre que se crió
prácticamente en las calles y se crió
con la familia de su padrastro que ni
siquiera era su familia es la historia
de un hombre huérfano de un hombre muy
pobre y de un hombre que desde muy
pequeño estuvo en las calles rebuscando
celaya y rebuscando sela en las calles
de villavicencio fue cuando conoció a
ese primer sacerdote el padre javier
guillén y ese sacerdote al notar que el
joven no tenía zapatos o estaba muy
desgastado esos zapatos lo enganchó con
eso con la necesidad de unos zapatos a
un niño de 14 15 años para invitarla a
su parroquia y abusarlo sexualmente
porque no se puede llamar de otra forma
esta relación que no se puede asemejar
la de un sacerdote con la de un niño que
no tiene papá que no tiene mamá que
tiene hambre y que tiene necesidades ya
luego después de abusar los 5 o 6 meses
de aburrirse depedro y de conocer a
otros menores de edad se lo pasó a otros
sacerdotes en los roto otros sacerdotes
y así indujeron a pedro a la
prostitución no sólo abusaron
sexualmente el industria de la
prostitución estos 38 sacerdotes pues
esta historia comienza cuando él tenía
14 15 años pero dura 20 años cuando ya
después pedro dice no más no quiero ser
víctima más de este abuso sexual de éste
de esta red de prostitución voy a
denunciar porque esta no es la vida que
yo me merezco y fue así cuando fue a la
arquidiócesis a denunciar y por
accidente el día que estaba denunciando
la arquidiócesis estas dos mujeres
socorro y olga a las 20 líneas de
villavicencio pues estaban allí en la
curia arzobispal y por accidente
escuchan esta denuncia y se enfrentaron
a la la jerarquía de villavicencio un
caso aberrante
que no sabemos qué va a ocurrir con él
no sabemos qué decisiones va a tomar la
fiscalía lo que sí sabemos es que los
sacerdotes aunque están suspendidos
siguen devengando su salario por parte
de la arquidiócesis mientras pedro está
huyendo escondiéndose de las amenazas
con pablo además de los abusos denunciar
lo que denomina el sistema de
encubrimiento criminal hablando de los
traslados no de sacerdotes denunciados
entre parroquias por distintas ciudades
las dificultades también para que las
denuncias siguen a las autoridades
penales a la justicia como es ese
entramado de impunidad que rodea a los
pederastas a los sacerdotes pederastas
los sacerdotes pederastas y la iglesia
en general sobre todo en nuestros países
están blindados santiago con algo que se
llama el concordato que fueron tratados
internacionales que firmó el estado
africano con muchos países en estos
momentos tiene concordatos con 19 países
13 de ellos en américa latina' y gracias
a un artículo de este concordato el
artículo segundo pues la iglesia puede
mantener algo se llama el archivo
secreto y yo creo que la discusión tiene
que estar centrada ahí en el archivo de
crédito en francia dicen que la
discusión es el secreto de confesión yo
la verdad no lo creo yo de verdad creo
que es en los archivos secretos que es
donde reposan todas esas denuncias
contra el niño contra sacerdotes por
abusos sexuales a niños niñas y
adolescentes ahí es donde tienen que
escuchar las autoridades eclesiásticas y
las autoridades civiles es ahí a donde
tienen que llegar infortunadamente
repito por cuenta de estos concordatos
pues ellos protegen esos archivos y la
autoridad si no puede llegar a
incautarlos no pueden llegar a hacer
allanamientos pero deberían hacerlo
porque estamos hablando de los crímenes
más aberrantes que son los crímenes que
se cometen contra los niños niñas y
adolescentes entonces olvidémonos que la
discusión está en el secreto de
confesión
la discusión está ahí tiene que estar en
los archivos secretos y eso y porque ahí
también por qué por qué por la pobreza
de la mayoría de víctimas que es uno de
los patrones pues la gente sin abogados
primero va a la curia primero va donde
el arzobispo a denunciar
a denunciar pues ellos guardan estos son
archivos tienen la posibilidad de
manipular a la víctima con millonarias
sumas y hacer que esta denuncia no
llegue a la autoridad civil entonces
tenemos que centrarnos es en los
archivos secretos allí está toda la
columna vertebral del descubrimiento
eclesial ahora este recorrido no fue
para nada simple ni lineal tampoco no
hubo muchos obstáculos que quisieron
interponer en lo que fue tu
investigación pero también tras la
publicación del libro verdad tuviste que
lograr por ejemplo y esto apunta a lo
que hablabas recién que la justicia
obliga a la iglesia a entregar sus
archivos sobre pederastia y te
intentaron callar con demandas con
amenazas también con recursos no
presentados ante la justicia juan pabló
que crees que provocan tus libros en la
iglesia por supuesto un rechazo así pero
que provocan también en una sociedad tan
católica como la colombiana
pues yo creo que mucha rabia la gente
tiene rabia la gente está abriendo los
ojos la gente si bien quiere a la
iglesia y esto no es un ataque a la
iglesia porque así yo lo he dicho
siempre
esto es una investigación periodística
que busca denunciar a criminales que se
esconden detrás de una sotana y que se
esconde en una institución que es muy
poderosa ese es el meollo del asunto y
ahí es a donde yo quiero enfocarme esto
no es un ataque a la fe entonces la
gente si tiene rabia pero la gente
también hoy en día pues sabe que puede
hablar sabe que ya no es esa iglesia
todopoderosa no sabe que no es esa
iglesia que mandaba incluso en asuntos
estatales
sabe que es esa iglesia que se puede
crecer cuestionar sabe que es esa
iglesia que también se puede denunciar
penalmente sabe que los sacerdotes y los
obispos y arzobispos pues no están por
encima de la ley nadie está por encima
de la ley y ellos antes de curas pues
son ciudadanos colombianos y tienen que
someterse al ordenamiento jurídico
colombiano por ende un sacerdote y un
obispo si cometen un delito tienen que
ir ante un fiscal y antes y no estar
escondidos debajo de la sotana del papá
o debajo de la sotana de los cardenales
que es lo que actualmente ocurre cuando
un poco nos adelantada se hace un
momento pero quisiera preguntarte por
supuesto cómo es la vida de pedro
imagino que estarás en contacto con él
sí pues está próximo a tener su séptimo
hijo que tiene tiene siete tiene siete
hijos
con tres mujeres diferentes yo incluso
lo cuento en el libro porque pues
estamos hablando también de que es un
hombre heterosexual al que indujeron en
la prostitución estos sacerdotes pero
con algo que él ni siquiera disfrutaba
le gustaba la necesidad y muchos otros
factores hicieron que él pues deambulará
de parroquia en parroquia por 20 años
hoy en día está esperando su séptimo
bebé de ver cómo sobrevive porque pues
es una familia grande para él un hombre
que se gana menos de un salario mínimo y
que en este momento no tiene ni los
pañales ni la ropita ni nada para
recibir en este mundo tan cruel a su
bebé pero está feliz está feliz de que
viene
él ha cambiado su vida después de que
denunció pues también está enfocado de
su matrimonio estaba enfocado en su
esposa está enfocado en sus hijos está
enfocado en reconstruir aquello que le
quitaron lo que le destruyeron en estos
20 años y entonces ahí va en su nombre
muy adolorido porque pues lo que vivió
fue una tragedia pero a la vez también
muy valiente porque pudo haberse quedado
callado pudo haber seguido lejos y no
haber dicho nada pero lo que hizo fue
voy a denunciar porque solo puede seguir
pasando porque esto le puede pasar a
otros niños niñas y adolescentes con
pablo nos quedan muy poquito tiempo unos
30 segundos nada más pero no quiero
dejar preguntarte que provocan en vos
las palabras del papa francisco cuando
hace referencia a la pederastia
yo creo que el papá tiene muy buenas
intenciones pero
aún le falta algo que aquí en colombia
alabamos el perro en que el perro en que
es esa voluntad esa voluntad verdadera
para erradicar la pederastia para
exigirles a todos los obispos
encubridores que saquen de sus filas a
estos hombres que están cometiendo
delitos yo creo que él es muy bueno para
dar muy buenos titulares y para vender
humo y aunque tiene buenas intenciones
pues esa voluntad todavía no la vemos
porque al final el papá lo que va a
defender es esa institución esa
institución que él representa que la
encabeza y que él dirige juan pablo
barrientos muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
nuevo santiago os encantado muchas
gracias un honor estar aquí gracias a ti
nuevamente ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre te invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y